there's really no difference between
here and home it's just everything's
compacted down to a 14 by 14 room
once you start staffing your lookout
you're going to be working 10 days on
four days off
late june until usually mid-september
it's a pretty quiet existence
this is my 24th season as a fire lookout
really it's just you in the wind and the
time just melts away
my name is leif haugen and we're at toma
lookout
a fire lookout is a structure that sits
on top of a mountain or ridge top that
has a good view of the surrounding
country and the staffer then is tasked
with living there for extended periods
to watch for fire
it's funny because i get a lot of
questions about the standard day you
wake up with the sun i mean it's hard to
sleep in a room of glass
much beyond sunrise
first thing i'll do is make a cup of
coffee
and usually i'll have that first cup of
coffee on the front porch
sit out there watch the sun come up
certainly every morning i go out for a
walk
[Music]
i check in at 10.
[Music]
hey good morning i have 67 degrees i
take the weather every day at 2.
skies are clear and check out at 4 15.
[Music]
have a good day
i think
the solitary nature when there's really
no fires going the only thing i might do
is checking on the radio twice a day
that might be the only time i really
talk unless i'm talking to myself
i think what's so tricky sometimes
talking about the lookout experience is
you're not talking to anybody about it
so you more intuitive you more
experience it i think that's why i
always use the term resonance because
you just can feel it and sense it maybe
that's fanciful but it certainly is the
way i feel about it you know you just
find yourself sitting on the porch
watching the world go by for hours on
end it's it's beautiful
when you look at you know the lifestyle
of fire lookout it can be a hard choice
at times too you know i'm missing a
wedding tonight
over the course of summer you might miss
a lot of stuff in your life but
certainly every summer i keep coming
back because living on top of a mountain
for days on end is just such a beautiful
chance at making a life of it
you